what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the century Marvel
Superman goes nuts so here's the thing
this picks up basically with Ryan topper
and mallerie now for those of you guys
who need to get caught up here we're
only one issue in so the playlist is
pretty short just one video long the
long and short of this is that the
century Robert Reynolds has been dead
for a while in Marvel Comics but its
powers had basically dispersed across
the world and what ended up happening
here is like four or five people
basically were Dawn with his abilities
and in fact people are still gaining his
abilities but Ryan topper is actually
traveling around and effectively killing
everybody who had developed the powers
of the century and then absorbing those
Powers into himself so effectively he's
Siler from Heroes just not as cool but
mallerie is one of the people who had
gained those abilities now mallerie was
wheelchair bound but when her powers
manifested she of course gained the
power of flight and so on and then took
off to the moon to the blue area where
she's able to breathe in space and
pretty much anybody can breathe in space
for those you guys who don't know the
blue area of the moon is well it's got a
whole history with the cre and the
celestials and all that kind of stuff
the long and short of it is that it is a
portion of the Moon that has oxygen so
people can breathe on it and in fact
different characters of Marvel Comics
have used the blue area as a base of
operations The Watcher has done it even
though he doesn't need to breathe the
X-Men have used it as a base of
operations the Inhumans use it as a base
of operations which they should have
stayed there right the best thing they
did was just leave the planet was just
go away that was like the best thing
they ever have done for anybody but Ryan
topper interestingly enough doesn't kill
mallerie and in fact he makes a comment
in saying that she seems kind of cute
and so he ultimately ends up leaving now
at that point we switch over to Time
Square in New York City to what is
obviously supposed to be Steven Yun the
guy who was going to play the century in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
Thunderbolts uh who of course as most of
you guys know by now dropped out of the
project so in the midst of all this he's
basically a street performer and he's
actually there on a first date with a
guy and they're all just kind of having
a good time and he's per forming his
whole thing right and whole kind of
stick then like a guy shows up out of
nowhere and just like shoots him right
just like shoots this dude in the face
but like when that happens he just like
everybody else gets a momentary glimpse
of the Sentry and this instance it is
when the sentury fought the molecule man
during dark rain so like it's this cool
thing because everybody thinks that he's
dead and in fact Paul comes running over
believing he's dead but then he suddenly
manifests the Cent's abilities and comes
back the kick to all this is everybody
thinks that he's a mutant and because of
what's going on in the fall of X right
now mutants are Public Enemy Number One
everybody hates those guys so they do
exactly what you would think they would
do in this situation where they
immediately just start like screaming at
this guy because all it takes is one
dude and that's one of the ironic things
about the X-Men Mythos is it just takes
one guy because like everybody's
clapping and everybody's like wow man
this guy's alive crazy and he's got
powers they think it's kind of a magic
trick but then like Paul chimes in and
he's like you manipulative sociopath Are
you a a freaking mutant right I mean I
guess first dates so he doesn't really
know the guy all that well but then he's
like no no no I'm not a mutant and
that's when like the whole mob turns
against him because that's the way it
works in Marvel Comics right it's like
all it takes is one person making an
accusation and the whole world turns
against you and so because of that he
basically just flees for his life gets
out of there as fast as he possibly can
and then he ends up chasing down the guy
who had basically gone to attack him but
then he's met by Ryan topper and the
cool thing about this is Ryan is just
like nice Resurrection trick back there
let's see you try doing that again and
the gu's like who in the world are you
right and he's just like my name's Ryan
topper right he's like I'm doing the
world a favor and he kills him right
he's like I'm killing you right now
because you were supposed to be in the
Thunderbolts movie but then you dropped
out of the film and now we have to kill
you off in the comic because if we don't
we will have a version of the century in
the comics that does not match the
version in the movie continuity will be
betrayed and potential fans will be
confused so he just kills him on the
spot like that's
it I mean of course he doesn't say that
but that's why Marvel did it because
literally Stephen Yun dropped out so the
thing about that is you end up jumping
several blocks away to Time Square right
to another place there and there's this
woman who's kind of lad because they're
getting everything all sorted out right
after the more recent symbiot attack and
all that kind of stuff which is cool
because this does give us a kind of uh
position for this story within the
Marvel Contin nudy meaning it takes
place seemingly of course in the
aftermath of the uh of the king and
black story line which we already knew
but it's taking place around the same
time as Marvel's gang war event which
started off strong and then became the
most least interesting event ever in
Marvel and so what this does is while
this girls kind of there she realizes
there's these three chicks who were like
shoplifting right and she's like so like
what are you guys doing and they're like
what do you think we're doing right
we're stealing brazenly because
everybody on Tik tok's doing it and
there's nothing you can do about it so
like they just go take off like they
just they go bolting and this chick's
like not a chance but in the middle of
that her powers kick in right and like
she gets this momentary glimpse of when
Thor fought the century so again like
it's just these cool little moments from
the Century's life and times now of
course she ultimately chases these girls
down and then helps them understand
their place in their bigger picture and
so following that you switch back over
to Ryan himself once this girl leaves
the store for the night and then Ryan
like literally kills this girl on the
spot and absorbs her power into himself
but switching back over to mallerie
mallerie's story has been a kind of
internal crisis because she doesn't
really know what her role is in all this
right like it created an existential
crisis in her life she knew what her
life was about she had her life on lock
down she had it all sorted and knew the
direction that everything was going in
the problem with this is that with
everything happening right now you have
this situation where she just doesn't
know what to do right like she was
suddenly bestowed with these incredible
powers and now it's this question of
like what do I do with these abilities
because the reality here and this is
something to kind of contend with right
this is one of the coolest things about
Marvel philosophically there's vast
differences between the average person
and the superhero and not even just
looking at things like powers and how
they handle their abilities and you know
with great power must come great
responsibility but like it's it's kind
of this example of like imagine if you
woke up tomorrow with like a billion
dollars in your bank account right and
you could go anywhere you wanted to you
would travel the world and then you
would probably buy a house and pay it
off and you would do all these things
that you've always dreamed of doing but
then what like then what comes next
right there's no greater purpose there
and so when you have a person like
mallerie who's just suddenly bestowed
with these incredible Powers these Godly
Powers right every the entire life she
had before is more or less over but the
fact is she can craft any kind of life
for herself and the things that she
viewed as impediment of course being
wheelchair bound not really sure if I
agree with that perspective but she saw
being handicapped as an impediment that
that's all gone now right she can just
do anything right but even then she kind
of has this whole conversation where she
says it's really lonely up here right
but the voices down there are warming my
heart a little I can literally hear
everyone even Clara my roommate Clara is
not religious but she's praying for me
to come back I wish I could tell you I
am okay I hope you found a new place to
live but I ruin the lives of everyone in
my building I can't forgive myself for
demolishing their homes even if it was
an accident and she says I need to make
things right I can't be scared of my
spasm anymore right basically her powers
kind of manifesting Beyond her ability
to control and she's like I know what
I'm capable of if that creep can figure
this out so can I and so seizing control
of her ability she takes off to the
Mediterranean Sea and then like rescues
these migrants right who are basically
Asylum Seekers and are just kind of
stuck dead in the water in their boat
right like literally just saving these
folks and what it does is it gives her a
kind of boost of confidence that she's
like I actually did something good with
these powers and this is kind of the
most moment that like every potential
superhero has Spider-Man had it Superman
had it Batman kind of has it a little
bit whenever he beats people up for j
walking or just anything that might be a
crime in any capacity right like
different superheroes have it in
different ways and so it's a cool little
thing to see that she is to a degree
coming into her own of course following
that she goes into like a self-righteous
political Spiel that nobody cares
anything about so what you do is you
switch over to Misty Knight and to
Jessica Jones they're the ones that are
hot on the trail of this whole thing
trying to figure out what's going on
right like these different people who
are manifesting the Century's powers of
course they pick up on Stephen Yun who's
basically dead now and of course like
this other girl who's basically dead as
well they don't know it and so it's kind
of like what's the bigger picture here
right like what's the bigger game that's
taking place and so what they end up
doing is actually hitting in on Ryan
topper right they ask like what about
the Ohio kid right the door Dash cyclist
the click clocker with CP and the
response is from Ryan's chat on a dating
app he took a train to meet someone in
Queens farad made transactions on a bike
repair and to load his metro card a
month ago most likely used the subway to
make his deliveries and all of
mallerie's clicklock followers which is
obviously an allegory to Tik Tok right
you couldn't think of a better name
Marvel come on man but anyway like a
frequent Shopper at Sweet Leaf
stationers right in Penn Station and so
basically they end up learning this guy
is following or has come across every
single person who has developed the
powers of the century and then within a
short amount of time of them
encountering each other that they all
basically end up dying so obviously Ryan
topper is the guy they're looking for
good job Misty Knight and Jessica Jones
you managed to put a three-piece puzzle
together congratulations but the cool
thing here is you basically switch up
right like outside of Dallas Texas where
like the Avengers of gather together to
fight the EOS which is kind of dope
because I haven't seen or heard from the
EOS in a long time and I kind of wish
they would come back to be honest man
these guys were minor league and best
they were on the level of like factor
three from the old Stanley Jack Kirby
X-Men stories if anybody remembers that
team from way back in the day God I'm
showing my age man but the fact is here
Ryan shows up out of nowhere Dawning the
full gear of the century and basically
said like Avengers mind if I cut in my
name is Ryan centry because I can't come
up with a cool name and I'm here to help
so the question has to be asked what
happens when basically Marvel Superman
who's a sociopathic serial killer ends
up fighting the Avengers that's the real
question here but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
if you guys need to get caught up make
sure you guys click this link to the
playlist and I will catch you all later